- Hey, everyone.
Welcome back to a new coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and I'm Firm Learning,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And today, I want to talk about
how to build a personal brand,
how to build an influence on LinkedIn.
I will first talk about why you,
as a young professional, should do that,
and why LinkedIn is the
perfect platform for it
at this point in time.
I will second spill the
tea on how the LinkedIn
algorithm works
to help you go viral.
I will third, give you some tangible tips
on profile optimization
to become a creator.
And last but not least,
I will share some tips on how
to build a content strategy
that will work towards your goals.
But before I just wanna spend
a couple of seconds talking
about why I'm actually justified
to even talk about this topic.
So for those of you who don't know me,
I started my social platform Firm Learning
in early 2020, started mainly on YouTube,
but then also growing on other platforms
such as Instagram and TikTok.
And LinkedIn for sure has
been a priority for me.
At the moment, I'm posting quite regularly
about three to five times per week.
And this enabled me to grow quite rapidly
over the last months.
And I will teach you in this video,
the very strategy that I used,
and the insights that I collected
on the way while doing it.
So let's start by talking
about why might be a good idea
for yourself to build a personal brand
and an influence on LinkedIn.
And let's first assume
the position of someone
who is already a senior
leader in an organization,
maybe a C-level executive
working somewhere.
Why might you be interested in LinkedIn?
I think there are three reasons for that.
First, employee recruiting.
So if an employee wants to find a new job,
that person would likely
look up the firm on LinkedIn.
And of course, if you
publish regular content,
that will be very instrumental
for potential candidates
decide whether your firm
is the firm to join or not.
Second, is corporate communications.
I would claim that for
most companies out there,
if their leadership would
post on LinkedIn compared
to an internal channels, for
instance, a corporate intranet,
likely they would be able to reach
more of their internal staff on LinkedIn,
likely their posts would be seen more.
So do think that LinkedIn
is a crucial tool
for corporate communication as well.
And the last but not least, of
course, also lead generation.
There are lots of examples,
how people are able to create customers,
attract business by using
LinkedIn in the right way.
This is a significant opportunity,
and I will teach you how
you can do this today.
But even if you're a young professional,
not necessarily in such a
leadership position yet,
if you use LinkedIn, you can
build your personal brand,
you can build an influence.
And with that, you have all the
benefits of being a creator.
The benefits of being a
creator in this day and age
have been widely described elsewhere.
Let's just say that the
opportunities for yourself,
both in terms of personal growth,
but also in terms of financial
or career opportunities
are very, very significant.
So why should you focus on LinkedIn?
If you want to build a
professional brand at the moment,
and there are many things
I could talk about,
let me focus on reach for
the purpose of this video.
At the moment, even if you
are still a small account,
you have the opportunity to reach
a significant amount
of people on LinkedIn.
And this might change over the next years,
maybe, maybe not, but at the moment,
that's for sure the case.
Let's compare that to another platform,
for instance, Facebook.
So let's say you have a Facebook
profile with 1,000 followers.
Well, if you release a post
without boosting it with ads,
likely only a fraction of
these followers will see that.
Let's just say roughly 5%.
So for 1,000 followers,
maybe your posts on average,
will get about 50 views,
just the fraction of your audience.
This is very different
right now on LinkedIn.
If you have thousand followers,
you can expect that your posts
will be seen by 2,000 people.
You can expect that a
multiple of your followers,
will regularly see your content.
And this is of course a very great
and significant opportunity.
And there are only very
few platforms at the moment
out there that will give
you a comparable reach.
Let us substantiate this
with some action numbers
and for data, I prepared some
data from my own account.
I was that I also used
for my Firm Learning work.
This was data point until
the end of the first half
of this year.
At that point in time, I
had about 18,000 followers.
And if I just took the
median post of all the posts
that I created, the median
post got about 30,000 views,
which is roughly two times the followers
that I had at that time.
But there was also post
that received 188,000 views
at that point in time.
So this is 10X, the followers that I had.
So this illustrates the
opportunities that are out there.
And I will talk more
about how to write exactly
these types of posts in a moment.
The second question that I often get is
whether I should post on my company page,
if you have one or on
your personal profile,
but if you're just an
individual, chances are higher
you only have your personal
profile available anyways.
But the good news is that
LinkedIn favors personal profiles
over a company pages
when it comes to reach.
And of course, the reasons for that are,
I'd say rather obvious, of course,
LinkedIn would love that the companies
rather pay ads, pay ad
money to boost their posts.
Whereas that's not that much of an option
for personal individuals,
but he just as an example,
the case of Volkswagen.
So Volkswagen, the company Volkswagen
has about 1.2 million followers,
and they just picked a post of them
that just got a couple of hundred likes.
And if you contrast that to Herbert Diess
one he recently was the
managing director of Volkswagen,
even though he had less
than 300,000 views,
his posts regularly get
over a thousand likes.
And of course there's some
variants among these posts,
but this is the general picture
that you see almost everywhere.
Personal profiles
definitely get more reach
than company profiles on LinkedIn.
So I definitely would encourage you
to use your personal profile as well.
And last but not least,
it seems very clear to me that
the development of LinkedIn
into an influencer and creator platform
is a key strategic objective of LinkedIn.
They're actively pushing it.
You can see it with all the
initiatives that the company
is coming up with.
For instance, the top
voices award that now
they award on a yearly basis.
If you ever felt like you
wanted to build an influence
on Instagram, on YouTube or
any of these other platforms,
but you were just too late.
Now it's your opportunity with LinkedIn.
Because if you start now,
you will definitely be still
early in the development
of LinkedIn as a creator platform,
the opportunities are out there,
you just need to grab them.
So let's next talk about
the LinkedIn algorithm
and why should you even care about how
the LinkedIn algorithm works
But in here again, I just looked at some
of my own personal data on
my Heinrich Rusche profile.
This is again the data
from the first half year
of this year.
And it just ordered all
the posts by the views
that they received.
And you can see that there's
quite a significant variance.
On the left hand side,
there are some posts that
got less than 10,000 views.
Again, let me remind you I
had about 18,000 followers
at that point in time.
But then on the right hand side,
I had a handful of posts
that exceeded 100,000 views
and my most successful post
measured in views received,
as I just also told you
earlier about 188,000 views,
and of course views matters because
if people don't see your content.
You cannot really spread the messages
that you want to spread.
You cannot really work towards
the goals and objectives
that you set for yourself
in the beginning.
And of course, if people
don't find your posts,
they also cannot find your profile.
And therefore you also cannot
grow your follower base
and your audience.
So let's look at how the
LinkedIn algorithm works
behind the scenes.
And this is very similar
to almost all the other
social media platform
algorithms work as well.
And I can imagine this to
work is that at the beginning,
if you post something LinkedIn
in the first minutes, hours,
and so on,
will show this post to a
fraction of your audience,
to a fraction of your followers,
or to a fraction of the people
who usually enjoy the
content that you create.
And then they observe what happens.
Are these people spending
time on the post?
Are they engaging with the post?
Are they leaving a comment?
So they have all these types of indicators
that let the algorithm
come to the conclusion,
whether this is a good post or not.
And so if this post performed well
in this very close group of
your most engaged followers,
then LinkedIn will likely show this post
to an extended group of your followers
to almost every one of your followers.
And will look again, how is it performing?
Is this performing well or not?
And again, if even with
this extended group,
LinkedIn comes to the conclusion that yes,
it's a good post then likely
it will show this post
to even more people.
Often also not even
your followers anymore,
but maybe people who LinkedIn believes
to have similar interests than
the people who follow you,
people who are similar to your followers.
And then again, regard
interest, are they interested?
Are they engaging? Are
they enjoying the post?
And then based on that step by step,
LinkedIn will show the
post to even more people
up until the point where LinkedIn
just doesn't find any
pockets of people anymore,
where the LinkedIn
algorithm would be confident
that these people would
enjoy your post as well.
And of course, sometimes
there are these unicorn posts
where the algorithm
comes to the conclusion
that actually more or less
everyone would enjoy it,
more or less everyone likes it.
And then sometimes you have
these super viral posts
that are seen by hundred thousands,
if not millions of people.
It's of course, very difficult to predict
to write something like this,
but occasionally this might happen to you.
So what exactly are these
signals that the algorithm
takes into consideration?
And what's here important for me to say
is though that I don't
have any inside knowledge
behind the same knowledge
of how the algorithm works.
The algorithm is first of all secret.
And second, it constantly changes.
What these are, are just
some common assumptions
where people test the things,
and this is what you
will find on many places
on the internet that this is how it works,
but it's definitely fair for yourself
to run your own experiment,
to see what really benefits
your specific account.
So let's talk about some positive signals.
First,
one of the most important
things is time on post.
One of the key metrics
that all of these platforms
are optimizing is to keep people,
keep users on the platform
for as long as possible.
Because of course the longer
people spend on the platform,
the more ads can be shown to these people.
And this is usually one of the
biggest monetization levers
that the platforms have.
So time on post is key,
but then of course, sharing
a post is a positive as well.
Because if you share a
post to your network,
you are saying that,
"Hey, this post is great.
It's important.
It's worth seeing and worth reading."
Next, commenting.
So LinkedIn wants to be the platform
where people engage with each other,
have conversations about topics,
and comments definitely
work towards this goal.
It's a key metric of engagement.
Next, sending a post, you can
send a post to other users,
to other people.
This is a positive
sign, of course as well,
because thereby you indicate
that it's worth sending and sharing.
Of course,
if people follow your profile
after they read your post,
this speaks towards the post as well.
And of course, liking a post
also liking other comments
will increase engagement in the same way.
And then of course there are
negative signals as well.
So of course, a big
negative signals already
of these positive don't
exist and out there.
But then surely if people hide the posts,
or tell the platform
that they don't want to
see content like this.
This is very negative.
If they unfollow you after
they read something from you,
if they mute the post from you/
Also, if they report the
post that you created,
these of course, negative
signals from the algorithm.
And if so far you received
any value from this video,
please hit the like
button for the algorithm,
and also follow or
subscribe to stay up to date
on all my content.
I will talk more about this going forward.
So would love you to stay on board here.
Next, let's talk about some little tips,
that you can do to improve your profile.
Especially with the goal
of becoming a creator.
And first of all,
I would encourage you to
use a background picture.
Many profiles still don't
use background pictures,
but if someone visits your
profile the first time,
for instance, after having
seen a post on their feed,
the background picture
is what really gives
your profile character.
And you can use it to
directly brand yourself,
make sure that the key
messages are transported,
and make sure that people
directly understand
what you are all about,
what they can expect if they follow you.
Next is the tagline.
So the tagline is the line
that is this displayed below your name.
The tagline is very important
because it's shown across
many places on the platform.
So usually whenever you write
a post, below your name,
there will also be the tagline present.
So this gives the first impression,
what is your background?
What are you all about?
Why should people be
interested in yourself?
So make it as concise and
as punchy as possible,
and avoid using too many words.
Next are hashtags.
So if you turn on the creator mode,
I will show you what this is in a moment.
You have the opportunity to add hashtags
like this on your profile.
This again helps the algorithm
to understand what the niches
that you're talking about, what
topics you are focusing on.
This is also called your authority
and will also help the
LinkedIn search to place you
in the appropriate search results.
For this last panel, least make
use of the featured section.
So LinkedIn provides you with a section
where you can hand select certain posts
that you feel like very well represent
what's going on on your
page, what you're doing,
what you're writing about,
the signature pieces of content
that you created in the past.
Make use of that.
Because again,
this is the ideal place to
give the first impression
to people who are new
to your personal brand,
are new to your profile,
to understand what you are all about.
Let's now also talk about the
creator mode on your profile.
You should find the option
to turn on the creator mode.
This will give you access
to some additional features
that are very relevant to creators.
So I would definitely
recommend you to do that.
For instance, you have
access to these hashtags
that I showed you a moment ago.
And another thing that
automatically happens
if you turn on the creator mode,
is that the main call to
action on your profile
changes from connect to follow.
So usually on standard profiles,
people see the connect button
so people can connect with the person,
but then of course the other person needs
to accept this connection
request this way.
Follow means that the people
want to see your content,
want to see your posts,
but the other person doesn't
need to approve that.
So the hurdles are lower.
People are not afraid that
maybe you won't accept them.
So if you change the
call to action to Follow,
this will enable and encourage
more people to follow you.
And therefore for you
to grow your audience,
of course, people can
still connect with you,
but this will not be
the main call to action
displayed on your profile anymore.
Let's now talk about the content strategy.
And in this section, I want
to talk about some tips,
some advice,
some little tactics and
hacks that you can use
to really create the best possible content
for the platform and maximize your chances
to eventually create some content pieces
that will also go viral and
thereby blow up your account.
And what's important in the very beginning
is that you should think about a niche,
a topic that you want to stand for.
So if people think about you,
what do they want to have in mind?
What are the key topics that you want
to associate yourself with?
So this is called your niche
and this should be rather specific.
You don't necessarily,
from the very first day,
need to have a very tangible
first niche in mind.
I think it's also fair just to start
with more generic content
and then over time
converge towards a niche.
But in the medium term,
you should develop this for yourself,
because think about it,
if you follow someone, why
are you following a profile?
Because you want to read
more of this type of content,
but if the content of a
person is all over the place
changes all the time,
why should someone follow you?
So think about your niche
first and then from your niche
you can then derive the content pieces
that you want to create.
And let's now start by
talking about the anatomy
of a successful post on LinkedIn.
And let's start with the hook.
The post should always
start with the hook.
So these are often one or two sentences
that just spark interest, create interest.
Let people want to read
more about the post.
Let's remember the time on post
is one of the most important indicators
for the LinkedIn algorithm.
So you want to excite people.
You want to motivate people
to read all the post,
because this is what will
get your time on post.
After the hook, there's the body,
and in this body in the
main part of your post,
you should always focus
on communicating value,
on communicating some insights,
things that other people can take away,
can learn from what you're writing about.
This is at least the rule of thumb.
You might occasionally deviate from that,
but the majority of your
posts should be based
on this framework.
What many people do wrong,
is that the write posts
completely self-centered,
just about themselves,
about their business,
all the great things that
they did in the past.
That's boring.
People don't want to read them,
make it about the value
that you can deliver
to the other person.
Next around the end of the post
end with the call to action.
So ask people to do something.
Here's also fair to vary these
call to actions over time.
Maybe encourage people to leave a comment,
'cause this, of course, sparks engagement,
or you can encourage
people to follow your page,
if they want to read more
about this specific
type of content, right?
So leave a call to action,
encourage people to do
something, because again,
this will also favor you in the algorithm.
Now I don't want to talk
about hashtags too much here
in this video.
I trust you're familiar with
them from other platforms.
The last thing that I
wanna talk about is that
it's quite striking that
at least at the moment
in the LinkedIn algorithm
posts that have an attachment.
So some type of picture, for instance,
or a slideshow or video
or anything like that,
they tend to perform significantly better
in the LinkedIn algorithm.
So I just looked at my top
10 best performing posts
and eight of these top
had some type of picture attached to them.
So in general,
I would recommend you
to always use a picture.
If you struggle to come up with a picture
that really meets the message of the post,
what many people do
is just include a random
picture of themselves.
And they just attach such
a picture of themselves
to the post.
I tried this out myself and
I can just only say it works.
It significantly improves
the reach of your content.
So let's now deep dive on the hook.
So on the first sentences
that you leave on your post.
Here, what you need to understand
that after a couple of lines
there is the so-called fold.
So LinkedIn only shows
the beginning of the post
and after a couple of
lines, then it just says,
"see more" and people need
to click on "see more"
to see the remainder of the post.
So here what's important is
that you're able to place
the full hook before the fold,
make sure the full hook is seen before
then this fold arrives.
And the good thing is that
where this fold is placed
is predictable.
And it depends on whether
there is an attachment to the post or not.
And if you follow the recommendation
that I just gave you a moment ago,
you will almost always
have such an attachment
attached to the post.
And if this is the case,
then this fold appears after
three lines of content.
You see this year in the
left example, three lines,
and then the fold appears.
And if there's no attachment,
this fold appears after five lines.
So here the example to the right,
you see four lines of text,
but then there's also an empty line,
an empty line, this counts as well.
So after five lines, then
there will be the fold.
So of course with your hook,
you want to encourage people
to click on "see more."
So maybe you are ending
with a question in the hook
that then you are answering
in the remainder of the post,
or maybe you make a rather
controversial statement
that then you explain in
the remainder of the post.
So encourage people to
click on "see more,"
because of course, just the
fact alone that people click
on "see more" is in itself already
a positive sign to the algorithm
that people find this post interesting,
and they want to learn more about it.
Let's now talk about another little hack
that you can do in your content strategy
to boost the reach of your post.
And this is occasionally creating posts
that really focus on boosting engagement,
focus on getting as much
engagement as possible.
And one type of post that
is very suited to do that
are surveys.
So you, in this example,
you can see that I created a survey,
it got about 40,000
impressions or 40,000 views.
And there were about 2,000 people
who participated in the survey
who clicked on an option in the survey.
So 2,000 people is quite
a lot for post of myself.
So you can often see that surveys
get quite a lot of engagement like this.
And the good thing is
if a person interacted
with your content in this way,
even though this person did
not necessarily follow you,
then this person is more
likely to, in the future,
see posts that you
created, that you wrote,
because LinkedIn now thinks that,
"Hey, this person might be
interested in your content."
So I would not encourage you
to always only create posts like this.
'Cause the truth is also
only because someone
participated in a survey,
doesn't necessarily mean that that person
is really interested in your content.
Doesn't necessarily
mean that another person
will go to your profile and follow you.
But occasional posts like this can help
to increase your engagement,
increase your views in the medium term.
Just one word of caution.
In the past, also earlier this year,
LinkedIn was quite swamped with posts
where people were doing surveys,
not with the survey tool,
which I think is also
rather new in LinkedIn,
but rather by abusing the
different types of like buttons,
you could participate in the survey
by clicking the like button
or the insightful like button
or the laugh like button and so on.
And using that as a survey.
And by that, of course
getting lots of engagement.
So recently I've not really
seen any of these types of posts
anymore on my timeline.
So I think here, this is an example
of how LinkedIn adjusted the algorithm
to not publish these types of posts,
which is why at the moment,
I would not recommend you to
create this type of content.
So let's now talk about another
strategy for your content.
And this is the build in public strategy.
Maybe you've already heard about it.
There was quite a lot of buzz around it.
And the main idea is this,
especially suitable
for maybe entrepreneurs
or anyone in leadership position
that you just talk about
what you're building, about the company,
the organization that you're building,
and just regularly share
some insights on that.
Maybe once per week,
you share your biggest
learnings of the last week
or the biggest achievements,
what you learn from them.
Maybe also some failures,
what you learn from that.
So this is just a strategy
where you can really
lift the curtains, let people in,
into your business and
provide value down the road.
This can of course help to create trust
with potential employees,
with potential customers.
This is a great strategy
to create new leads.
I'm just show you here an
example of a gentleman.
So for full disclosure, I
don't know this gentleman.
I also don't want to
endorse any of his content
or his activities.
I just thought this was a
nice example of where someone
is doing exactly that.
There are many other examples out there.
So let's now talk about
some typical mistakes
that many people are doing.
And here I'm now referencing
this book from the great
Gary Vaynerchuk, "Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook."
Maybe some of you have seen it.
And the big notion of this book is that
if you want to be
successful in social media,
in the world out there,
rather focus on the jabs
and be rather measured
in your use of right hooks.
And in this picture, the jab
is a piece of content posts
that focuses on delivering
value for the audience.
Whereas the right hook is the message,
but you have some type
of commercial interest.
Maybe you want someone to
become a customer of yourself.
And as the title already says,
jab, jab, jab, right hook,
right? So for every right hook
for every commercial message,
make sure that there's a good number
of really value creating
messages before that,
or to say differently,
your profile should not look
like a big advertisement.
And this is frankly what I sometimes see.
People also do wrong with
this built in public strategy
where they just talk about
how great the organization is,
how great their company is.
This is not what people want
to read all of the time.
In your content, focus on
delivering value for others.
And if you do that consistently,
then people will very much understand
if you occasionally also
place this right hook
with your own commercial interest.
Let's now talk about sharing other posts,
and in principle, there's
nothing wrong with that.
You just need to be aware
that how the system,
the algorithm works is that
if you share another post,
that mainly helps the
reach of the other post.
So the other post with an
often be shown to more people,
potentially also to more
people in your audience.
Build a post that you yourself create.
By sharing another post,
potentially also with some comments,
this post in itself will often only get
a fraction of the views than such a post.
What usually get so sharing
other posts is great
for the post that you're sharing,
but often doesn't help you.
If you want to create a post yourself,
that gets lots of reach, lots of use.
So depending on your goals,
you might still want to share
the other post to support it,
or you just decide to create
a new post by yourself
that picks up some of the main messages
and then has higher
chances to get the reach.
Let's now also talk about
linking external resources,
for instance, adding a link to
another website to your post.
And here, the truth is
also that this is very bad
for the reach of your post.
I've recently seen an
analysis of another person
with a conclusion,
the post with external
links receive on average,
only 1/6 of the reach of a
post without external links.
And the reason for that I
think is also quite obvious.
Of course, LinkedIn likes to
keep people on the platform.
LinkedIn, doesn't like to
lead people from the platform,
which is why they're punishing posts
that have these external links.
So my advice would be that
if you do want to link
to an external page,
don't put the link in the original post,
but rather put the link in the comments
and then you can write on
the post something like,
"Oh, okay. Link to the
page and the comments."
And this will then to some extent,
bypass this reach penalty
that LinkedIn otherwise
would put on your post.
But now I would love to hear from you.
Do you have any other LinkedIn
strategies and tips to share,
leave a comment here in
the comments section.
I'd love to get all your insights
or learn from you as well.
Again, if you enjoyed it
or took any value from it,
please hit the like
button for the algorithm,
and also subscribe and follow
to stay up to date on all the content.
Big, big thanks to all the
members of Firm Learning as well.
Thank you for your support.
My name is Heinrich
I'm the creator of Firm Learning.
Talk to you again soon.